We just arrived this
relation here-- the relation
between the differential of
the speed of the rocket sled
and the differential of
the mass of the rocket.
And we want to ultimately
get the speed of the rocket.
So we have to apply a technique
called separation of variables
and then we want to integrate.
What we're going to
do is, first we're
going to divide-- multiply
by dt so that falls away,
and we are left with m
r d v r equals d m r u.
And we're going to shuffle
the m onto the other side.
And we're left
with d v r equals--
u is a constant-- so
that goes up front,
and then we have d m r over m r.
That's an equation that
we can integrate now.
And we can do that.
And the tricky bit
is that we need
to take care of the
integration limits here.
We have v r, and actually
these now are all primes.
So we have v r going from v0.
That is our initial
condition here 2vr
prime of equal vr of t.
And for the mass, we
have m r prime equals m0.
Actually, not quite m0, it's
2m0 because the initial mass
of this is the dry
mass and the fuel mass,
so that's 2m0, so this
is the initial mass.
And then we go to m r
prime equals m of vr.
All right, so let's do that.
We're going to get vr
minus v0 equals u 1 over m,
integrated gives us lm, so lm.
And then we can immediately
do this here over 2m0.
And well, we
ultimately want this,
so this is the r
of t, of course.
And then we got v0 plus
u l n m r over 2 m0
And that is our equation.
So what does this
equation tell us?
M r, the mass of the
rocket is less later
on than it was before,
which means this term here
is going to be
less than 0, which
means the velocity is
our initial velocity
minus something.
Which means we have a
decrease in velocity,
which means my sled will
eventually come to a stop.